okay the time being 10:12 we will get
started thank you uh for those who were
able to make it in I know we have
several people listening
online um who weren't able to make it
in
so with that I'll open the public
hearing on hb1
1422 and first we'll call up
Bill thank you very much Mr chairman to
the members of the House Ways and Means
Committee
I'm rock 25 the town of Salem uh today I
speak before you to introduce House Bill
1422 the consumer tax relief act a
crucial piece of legislation that that
not only reflects our commitment here in
New Hampshire to fiscal responsibility
but also addresses the pressing needs of
the Granite Staters in these challenging
times this bill is more than just a
fiscal adjustment it is a Beacon of Hope
and a testament to our vision for New
Hampshire a vision that Pro uh positions
our state as a leader in Freedom and
prosperity not only in the Northeast but
throughout the nation in the current
economic climate marked by inflation and
escalating costs of living the people of
New Hampshire are facing unprecedented
Financial pressures the policies
emanating from Washington DC have
contributed to a surge in the cost of
goods affecting the daily lives of our
citizens month after month Granite
Staters are grappling with the rising
costs and expenses that are stretching
their budgets to the breaking point in
these times when factors are beyond our
control are making life harder for our
people it is imperative that we take
decisive action to provide relief where
we can
one of the most effective ways we can do
this is by cutting taxes here in New
Hampshire and that is precisely what the
consumer tax relief act aims to achieve
in New Hampshire we have found great
success by lowering our taxes on
employers and our economy and we've seen
the economic boom that has come from
previously passed relief we've lowered
our business taxes here in New Hampshire
and we're in the final year of our
interest and dividends tax an income tax
that was placed on granite sator that is
finally coming to an end but we cannot
rest on our Laurels and get comfortable
with our tax structure as it currently
stands we must be even more aggressive
and efficient at identifying future tax
cuts and our options to provide relief
to Granite Staters the consumer tax
relief Act is a direct response to the
economic hardships faced by our citizens
by proposing sign significant tax
reductions we are not only easing the
financial burden on our residents but
also sending a clear message that we are
here to support them in tangible ways
lowering the business profits tax and
the business Enterprise tax aligns with
our original vision of these taxes when
the BET was implemented fostering a more
business-friendly environment and
encouraging economic growth this growth
is crucial for providing job
opportunities and stability to our
citizens moreover the elimination of the
Communication Service tax and the
reduction of the meals and rooms tax
below Massachusetts rates are strategic
moves to enhance our state's appeal and
competitiveness these reductions will
directly benefit consumers by lowering
the cost of essential services and
dining out helping to mitigate the
impact of inflation on everyday expenses
and speaking for a border community in
our state lowering the meals and room
Stacks below Massachusetts will help
attract customers to New Hampshire for
not only restaurants dining out but for
large event venues uh that are we're
losing out to other states around us
furthermore more by increasing the
distribution rate to the meals and rooms
Municipal Revenue fund we are ensuring
that the funds our municipalities are
expecting under the current budget and
rate are not affected by Future cuts to
the meals and rooms tax rate the
consumer tax relief Act is a proactive
step towards alleviating the financial
strain faced by Granite Staters due to
external economic pressures it is a bill
that not only offers immediate tax
relief but also lays the groundwork for
long-term economic resilience I urge my
fellow representatives and all
stakeholders to support this bill
recognizing it as a necessary measure to
support our citizens in these
challenging Economic Times and to secure
a more prosperous future for New
Hampshire thank you for your attention
I'm happy to take any questions I know
there are others here to testify as well
but thank you all thank you question yes
representative shamberg uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
taking this question with all these
reductions
is there a local tax increase on
property in each of the towns with this
reduction no I so I structured it
through OS so that as we're reducing the
meals and rooms tax the formula that
sends to the local Municipal fund is
increasing proportionally so that only
the state side of the revenue is
reductions yes uh may I have a copy of
your statement yes I did give one to the
clerk and to the chairman interim here
for a little bit this copy when I'm if
it's here I'll find it thank you okay
thank
you representative
Aly thank you
um I'm do you understand what this does
to the state government which also is
suffering from the same inflation as
everybody else is on I'm
updated the BET BP cuts that you are
making from 21 to
23 using uh I I believe the
CPI uh and I added everything together
and one quarter of the revenues that our
state collects are going to disappear by
2027 so I a little bit later depending
depending on the length of time that you
were were moving these things out and
and do you realize that we have a long
history in this state of cutting taxes
at the state level uh not being able to
afford various Services we you used to
give or or subsidies we used to give to
the towns and the towns then having
to replace that by creating new less
efficient services at their level which
are go on their property taxes so I I do
understand the history you're referring
to representative Al me as a member of
the House finance committee I do
understand the state of revenues and
spending in our state um I I think I
will disagree with you on a on a
fundamental basis as to whose money this
is that we are cutting uh when we cut
taxes uh in this year um it's really the
projections for the reductions this year
are in line with what were our current
surpluses will probably end up in being
in June um so I don't think we're after
going to cut into Services uh certainly
not this year um and this really does
just offer a road map for not only
future legislators but future budget
writers future Governors to understand
what where they want to go when it comes
to tax relief in the Granite State uh
we've seen successful tax cuts in New
Hampshire increase Revenue that the
state's received due to the nature of
the tax cuts that led to economic
activity um and so I believe just as
we've seen in the past we'll see these
tax cuts increase Revenue uh through
will any other
questions okay thank you great thank you
I have to head off to house finance now
but thank you very much for the time
go good morning again thank you Mr
chairman representative Tim MCU from
marac Hillsboro County 12 back again to
talk about giving some more of the
people's money back to them last week we
spoke specifically about the meals tax
today's package is a little more broad
so for 34 years the communications tax
has plagued New Hampshire so much for
free speech in New Hampshire
it's flu season if you haven't noticed
it's
actually the influenza of inflation that
I hope this tax cut will help us
fix so this is the people's money and
they want to spend it like they spend
their own so we need to take action on
this bill on
1422 and pass the consumer tax relief
act nearly every day in some fashion
both on the campaign Trail during
regular interactions just on a
day-to-day basis I hear from
constituents and citizens in New
Hampshire that they're having difficulty
paying their bills with inflation Rising
difficulty putting food on the table and
gas in the tank these tax cuts are small
ways to help them do that small but
incredibly meaningful ways for the
workingclass families of New
Hampshire so I urge you to take a hard
look at this look at where New Hampshire
falls within the communications tax and
I'll email this testimony to you
given a copy to the clerk already but
there's a there's a map in it that shows
you where we are in relation to other
states in terms of communications tax
we've gone up and down the current rate
is 7% there's federal tax too uh on top
of that as I mentioned last week the
meals tax meals and rooms tax revenue
has had a significant Surplus uh and
should be able to support this small
reduction and make us even more
competitive with uh the region same with
the communication tax for many years ago
we needed the help building out the 911
system which it's done so the job of
that is done and it was designed to help
support the infrastructure of landlines
I'm not sure about you but I don't use a
landline and I haven't used one for a
decade so that's it I'll keep it short
and sweet on a snowy day but there's uh
about a hundred great reasons and ways
we can make these tax cuts work they're
ramped in and very similar to the
package I presented to you last last
week it keeps the town holes keeps the
towns whole and in fact increases the
amount of the percentage of the local
distribution as these tax cuts ramp in
the meals meals meals tax reduction bill
from last week set a specific amount as
a minimum uh this does it slightly in a
slightly different fashion but
accomplishes the same objective by
increasing the percentage of that
allocation as the tax comes down the
distribution goes
up okay thank you represent
buery thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question if I uh remember
correctly you run a a successful
business over in uh uh marac and a bit
of an entrepreneur if you if you will
use that term um could you kind of
explain to us the effect on taxes and
how that allows a business to grow or
doesn't allow a business to grow and
what happens when you cut the taxes uh
the previous presenter indicated that
the state has received an increase in
Revenue when taxes went down which seems
to follow the laugher curve to some
degree and that's something we need to
be aware of because that allows for some
latitude but I'm trying to make sure
we're not going over that that that's a
great Point thank you for your question
representative Wy um so it's it's my
belief and my experience that when the
when the business has a lower tax burden
it let lets us put money back into the
economy in hiring right that's the the
number one asset of any company is its
people and if I can hire better people
or more people employ more people I
stand to be more competitive in the
market and with a decreased tax burden
on some of the business side I'm able to
do that and I'm probably also able to
attract them to New Hampshire to reside
in New Hampshire retire in New Hampshire
raise their kids here
uh so I think it has an incredible
effect on stimulating the economy and
like representative Sweeny before me
said uh the net effect is likely to be
increased and historically has been
increased Revenue to the
state thank you Mr chair yes
representative thank you um have you
looked at the piece written by uh Phil
slon of the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute
on on those tax cuts the history of
those tax cuts uh Phil slon was a very
uh able state auditor until he moved to
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute he proves pretty
conclusively that the tax cuts that we
have done so far did
not uh
in
decrease uh that did did not increase
our
taxes uh over the over the short or the
long run and I think that everybody here
should take a look at that before but um
I can't say that at this point so do you
have you read that thank you
representative all may I'll do you one
better I spent a day in the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
seminar so not only did I listen to to
it and disagree with how they propose to
spend on numerous numerous social
programs that expand government increase
the side of size of government increase
bureaucracy and ultimately increase the
tax burden I listened to it for the
better part of a day I think some
members of this committee were at that
seminar with me just a few months ago uh
and I also did take a look at that paper
which I don't believe was peer-reviewed
or published in any reputable Economic
Journal so I did have a hard look at it
and I thank you very much for bringing
that up in fact I think everybody should
I agree with you take a look at it and
also take a look at where that
particular group uh is advocating that
that money gets
spent because it's not to make
government
smaller representative shamberg thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
taking this
question um so if this tax bill
passes the cost of products bought at
hardware store Car Sales grocery stores
Etc uh will decrease for the consumers
at the point of
sale tell me your your list of outlets
again sorry uh you said car dealers
hardware stores hardware stores grocery
stores Etc will the cost to the consumer
decrease at the point of sale it's it's
impossible to predict entirely But
ultimately yes as you know we don't have
a sales tax on groceries or things in
the hard ware store uh but ultimately it
will decrease the cost of doing business
uh and that makes New Hampshire a better
place to live work retire Etc so we you
asked you asked about some very specific
places where we don't currently have a
sales tax as you
know that we do either there
are taxes they pay as a either bet or
BPT or I just would like to know are we
going to see cost of products go down
with this well I wish I had a crystal
ball but I do believe that yes that is
the economic theory that yes they they
will it will certainly make it a better
place to live and more attractive and
easier on our consumers who trying to
tank yes represent ORS thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question last week we had a young lady
in here Hotel owner and her concern was
if we
change the tax rates tourists would get
confused or be resistant to change and
it might hurt her business so do you
think by reducing this tax or taxes that
it's going to help tourism or is it
going to diminish tourism or uh slightly
less than expected um I so I don't think
others will be confused they'll be
pleasantly surprised and once word
spreads uh it will only
help
thanks I'm sorry I don't have a ton more
time I've got to get back to to Commerce
uh for a couple of things but I could
take one more if there was one
more any other
questions seeing none oh I'm sorry
representative fellows um yes one of the
statements you made is that you know
consumers uh people residents of the
state are telling you that they're
having a hard time putting um you know
meal on the table and paying their bills
um when I hear from residents of the
state what they're telling me is that
their property taxes are too high and
that that's what's causing um them to
feel insecure being able to maintain
their home and also people complain
about we know a housing crisis we have a
housing crisis right now and part of the
people who are renting are also having a
hard time paying rent and of course in
both of those situations a considerable
amount of
what um they have to pay is property tax
so what do you say to Consumers who are
telling you that they're having a hard
time with their rent or their property
tax that's a great question and thank
you representative fellow for that
question I think that you asked me the
same question last week on the the meals
tax reduction and I'd say very simply we
need to reduce property taxes and do you
think it will be uh easier or harder for
tenants or residents paying property tax
will it be easier for them to pay those
property taxes that fund the schools and
things if they have more money in their
pocket through these tax savings I
contend that if we put more money in
their pocket by reducing these taxes
it'll be easier to pay those other taxes
where there's quite a bit of resistance
to reduce property taxes my first choice
would be of course reduce property taxes
reduce them all reduce them all so
that's how I think it'll impact it
thanks thanks a lot I appreciate it
follow up just focusing on property
taxes do you have some suggestions on
how to reduce
that I think this tax package is a good
start uh and that will help bear the
burden of paying those property
taxes
right thank you very much thank you
members thank
you okay next up we have uh Greg
Moore
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
speak on this delightful morning uh my
name is Greg Moore I'm a regional
director for Americans for Prosperity
I'm here today to testify in support of
House Bill
1422 I will tell you that when I uh was
talking with the sponsor about this
legislation I discussed it as a alart
menu of tax reductions and I'd like to
spend a little bit of time talking about
how we prioritize uh the tax
reductions as you know this uh Americans
for Prosperity led the effort since
since 2015 to reduce the BET and
BPT and we think that that is the the
the right way to start which is a top
priority for this committee as you guys
are considering your Revenue pictures is
the business Enterprise tax the BET has
been reduced four times since 2015 the
BPT five times since since 2015 and uh
we think it's important important signal
to small businesses to try to provide
them more tax relief BPT does help it
does help to create a positive uh
economic development in the State uh we
think that that's Al also worthwhile
Endeavor the the two consumer taxes
while we we think it's great that we put
more money into pockets of of granted
Staters and I think that's critical at
time when inflation has been what it's
been through the last few years uh
ultimately we don't see them as having
the same multiplier effects as a bet and
a BPT so uh we view them as probably the
the as less important as far as this tax
tax package go so um that's our view
from from from Americans for Prosperity
I have a couple things that i' want to
point out uh first and
foremost um I did read the fiscal policy
Institute study I have some concerns
with with the way it was laid out that
was those concerns are born from
somebody who has been trying to put
together a study over the Arc of the
last seven or eight years I've struggled
to find an economist who'd be willing to
take it they listed out a number of
issues and variables that would have to
be factored into it and in reading the
study by the fiscal policy Institute
none of those appear to have been uh
considered in in the process that's why
I have some concerns with that study and
then finally I'd like to point out that
as someone who worked at
HHS uh and knows how at the state level
how we treated Federal money
the concern for the state sending
subsidies to local cities and towns I I
think it's a little bit I I ask myself
why would cities and towns treat State
money any differently than than the
state agencies treat Federal money and
that is and that is they don't put as
much scrutiny into into the expenditure
of it as they do the money that they
have to raise in taxes by themselves so
that's that's uh one reason why I think
that just focusing on state subsidies to
the cities and towns is often misguided
and and often does doesn't lead to the
most efficient valuable use of resources
so with that I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you um I have one um I
missed one point I think you said was it
the communication Services tax that you
said was a little lower in your priority
uh yes communication Services tax and
even even uh even the meals and rentals
tax the meals and rentals tax uh I've
talked to a number of of uh people in
that in in the hospitality industry they
indicated to me that that the reduction
from 9 to 8 and a half really hasn't
spurred any additional growth uh on
their on their side now we have seen
more Revenue but that largely has to do
with the fact that the just food prices
since the pandemic have spiked and that
has driven up overall Revenue as well as
labor prices have spiked so as a as a
consequence we're getting more Revenue
uh because they've had to drive their
increase their their cost but uh they
don't attribute any additional uh growth
in terms of volume as a result of the
reduction from 9 to 8 and a half okay
thank you uh yes representative shamberg
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Moore
for taking this question would a more
effective relief for businesses be a
safe harbor approach versus a reduction
percentage reduction to protect
society the complications of tax policy
you're right there there a lot of
different ways to skin a cat and I and
thank you for the question but there are
a lot of ways to skin a cat um we think
we think just an overall rate reduction
s sends a better signal particularly to
small
businesses yes representative
Yori thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Mr Moore
the question has been raised regarding
uh property taxes and and and they're
increasing in
in the appropriation of that in addition
we have an inflation action that's
taking taking place because of an
increase
in paper money that's been
created
which to some degree accounts for the
increased Revenue numbers that you just
just mentioned with meals and rooms but
who has the ultimate control over how
much the property tax is that the state
in New Hampshire or is that the
municipal government in New Hampshire
including School
Board absolutely complicated question
because of course the Dr sets the final
rate so I don't want to exclude that
point but but ultimately the spending is
being driven at the local level and we
have seen significant increases I know
that um someone who's in the room who uh
works for a different organization
prepared to speak on a different bill
has spent a fair amount of time looking
at the the increaseing and gross in in
education budgets at the local level um
and and he's written some pretty
compelling papers as to why that should
be the focus area for those folks who
are really concerned about property
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you thank
you uh the last pin card I have right
now is um Lauren O Sullivan and Kean
questions
Mr
yes could they start by telling us what
they just changed they've sent us around
note so uh the change on the fiscal note
just corrects a couple of typos that
were in the published fiscal note oh and
none of them are significant to our
understanding that is correct okay thank
you so for the record uh good morning my
name is Lauren O Sullivan I am the
senior Financial Analyst at the
Department of
Revenue and I'm Kim Mong tax policy
council with the Dr um the department
does not have a position on the bill uh
we did prepare a fiscal note on the bill
and uh we had uh distributed the the uh
fiscal no quick guide to the committee
um before the weekend um just I guess
just a quick recap on the bill um so the
the bill reduces the U the tax rates for
the BPT bet um the CST and then up to a
uh repeal of the
CST uh the reduction in the M&R rate uh
an increase in the distribution to the
uh uh mun Municipal um uh mpal revenue
account and then
[Music]
um and in the fiscal noqu guide you will
see that we have prepared a uh sort of a
summary sheet in terms of the fiscal
impact of all the uh the combined um
adjustments that would be made to the
rates the just a few points that we
wanted to point out is uh just the uh
the mechanical um I guess the technical
ISS issues that we've identified through
the
bill first off is the uh for
CST um that we would suggest a an
applicable uh taxable period beginning
date so for uh for the rate reduction we
would propose a uh the taxable period
beginning on or after July 1 2024 that's
in consistent with the the language uh
of what we see that the intent of the
bill is and then for the repeal will be
uh the the language would be something
like the taxable periods beginning on or
after gen 1 of
2027 there is also other um other parts
of the the CST in the uh in the statutes
that CST touches so we have actually uh
compile
that uh all the xray language where uh
all the other CST Parts would be
touching but not within the CST statute
itself this essentially is uh take
lifted from uh I believe it was a house
bill one or House Bill two a few years
ago um from uh where there was I might
have been last session actually uh for
the when the uh one of the bills was uh
suggesting proposing the repeal of the
CST so that's a list of the additional
language that we thought that should be
in there as
well and the other item is for the
M&R uh
tax one of the items that we thought uh
the timing of the uh the the rate
reduction would be a bit too quick as uh
not the rate reduction but the the
exclusion of the uh taxable meals of a
dollar or less from the uh from uh
taxable M&R we thought that potentially
that the timing might be a bit too short
notice for The Operators to implement so
maybe to extend that a bit further out
um we also had some concerns that
potentially um that operators might not
be able to implement the uh the zero tax
on taxable meals of less than a dollar
from the other items of um meals taxable
meals that that they sell
um and then one other thing is just the
uh the applicable taxable period uh
language uh something to do with the uh
you know to to match it with a with a
taxable period so the suggest that with
a pushout date potentially something on
questions yes representative Aly yes I'd
just like to check um you use uh when
you're looking at business taxes you go
back to
um the time when the business tax
revenue had been thoroughly completely
audited so we so you calculated the cost
of the BET BP changes based on FY
21 22 21 I think but 2122 I did it I did
it the right way when I did it um does
it make sense to you that given all of
the inflation and everything including
our taxes uh that on the on the
2122 um cost should be adjusted for the
inflation up thank you for the question
I think that that's an excellent point
um as you know that we can only
project um calculations using static
analysis um and we did use the texia 21
data and that is uh returns Tex year TX
year 2021 returns that have been
submitted up to and that would be the
like
the that we use the the tax year 2021 uh
return data and that would be the the
most recent uh full tax year uh data
that we would have received received um
from the taxpayers
um yes potentially uh with with know
inflation rates and then uh change in
tax laws from 21 through 22 all all that
would potentially change the uh the
fiscal impact um
however we were not able to to adjust
those calculations um further thank you
and those would have been primarily
collected in fiscal years 22 and 23 as
well as refunded in 23
forward yes I know it gets really
complicated yeah that's why we like to
use the tax year because that's the most
complete set and everyone is on the same
law that year thank you but then we're
two years
behind representative shamber thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking this
question on table 8 says the cumulative
estimated impact per year
then you give us a total six years out I
realize it could be up or down you're
not sure but is that $2 billion change
over these next six
years is estimated by the
[Music]
Dr on the revised schedule I guess it is
yes I just want to make sure I'm reading
this right two billion
so uh for some of the proposals those
are fully realized prior to 2031 so
you'll notice like um for example like
the BET rate change you'll see that's
pretty static from fiscal years 29 30
and 31 so really um when when you get to
that two billion at that point those
numbers may very well be I guess baked
into those business decisions in those
years and how the um how much tax is
representative uh
UL just because it's not there those
figures when you talk about them being
baked in your comment regarding baked in
is the closest you can get to uh a uh an
aggressive uh analysis of potential
business activities other than that
these figures are arithmetic or a static
correct display uh assuming no change
changes in current behavior and then but
when you use the term baked in you're
assuming a business
Behavior so that is correct yes for for
when we start forecasting out okay I
just want to make sure that we all
understand that their that their U
crystal ball is cloudy as so is ours
makes
our
yeah yes representative fellows um yes
this this is not really a question about
this particular bill but I do have a
question about the document here that
says fiscal note quick guide and it it
references well it has the bill number
now but it it also has the the LSR
number and that there are
recommendations in here that
are they're tech technical kinds of
things and that they're not in the
fiscal note so I was surprised to see
this because my understanding was that
technical issues are supposed to be in
in the fiscal note and so I I just don't
know this pops up and I don't know kind
of like why it's here and how when I was
this available earlier that kind of
question that is a an excellent question
rep representative fellow uh so when
when the Dr prepares the fiscal note
upon request from the OS
uh sorry from the LBA uh we prepare it
with a form that has one section of the
form has is the technical defects uh
tech technical mechan mechanical defects
and we submit that to the LBA and the
the fiscal note that is attached to the
back of the bill is a summary from the
LBA from what we've submitted and um and
for our purposes we thought that um all
the other point that so some of the
points that we made on our submission to
the LBA might not have made it into the
fiscal note at the back of the bill and
that's why we prepar a fiscal not Quake
guide just for a complete um
picture follow up so and so this is the
quick notes when when you bring them
because I assume sometimes you don't
think there's any need to do that you
know if there isn't any any um correct
when big issue so then we we I'm trying
to find out when we would likely see
this so this is a time when you testify
that we you would bring this if you
thought it had additional information
yes additional information that was not
in the fiscal note at the back of the
bill um that we have identified dur when
we were reviewing the uh proposed
legislation and uh so we we will bring
it and we would testify to it follow up
just one tiny followup um would you have
shared this with um well this is this is
the second version of this bill but
would you have shared this with with the
prime sponsor if if they had asked or uh
we only submit that to the LBA so I I do
not know the process between the LBA and
the prime
sponsor representative Aly thank you
just um since we're talking with the Dr
I think maybe I can give a little bit of
History this committee requested the
quick notes quite a long long time ago
now we did it because the fiscal notes
themselves were a lot shorter than they
are now but it still I think serves a
purpose they are providing it for each
bill they were in your email last
week I forget when in your email
but thank you any other questions of the
Dr okay thank
you I now have one additional uh pink
heck
heck good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I did not plan
to testify today in your inbox you will
see an email for me um because it's very
Sim it would have been very similar to
my prior testimony and I was concerned
with the beautiful weather which is
great for our tourism industry that I
might not make it here today but thank
you for being here I did feel compelled
to make sure that I explain to things
that I heard um and questions asked
around so there's no confusion how this
works on the municipal side around the
meals and
rooms so while we don't have a position
on the policy piece of the bill and we
continue to appreciate that the sponsor
has made sure that the municipal side
would remain whole um it was said in
testimony that municipalities are less
deliberate I'm paraphrasing with the use
of these funds um how the municipal
budget is set is revenues and expenses
don't really talk to each other they
only talk twice a year what you raise in
appropriate what you approve in our
budgets is in a a calculation over here
and the revenues are over here so we
typically estimate what revenues might
be during the budget process just
because we get more Revenue in that
gives us no legal authority to spend
those dollars so they are as I showed
you on the last uh sheet that was handed
out they would be applied as Revenue in
the tax rate setting time so for example
in
2021 um the prior year a city or town
would look at what their distribution
was and from 2017 to 2021 it was 68.8
Million Statewide they would have used
that number to estimate their revenue
when they were setting their budget then
the law change
and we see in 2022 we got $100 million
that additional Revenue was reported on
the MS 434 when we set our tax rate and
went to immediate property tax reduction
so there was no ability to spend more
money or be less deliberate with the
budget and the second thing I did want
to cover is that the four rates the four
tax rates are municipal rate it I
suppose you could have a village
District too the school the swept the
State education rate the county and and
potentially a village District if you
have one in your community or more are
set separately with their own
calculations meals and rooms only
impacts the municipal tax rate
collection and I heard the school was
brought up and I wanted to just C
clarify that so I did want to let you
know that anytime we receive more money
and meals in rooms that than what we
anticipated and we estimate
conservatively but every year that's
gone up that has been direct property
tax relief during the tax rate setting
in December so thank you and I can
certainly take any questions thank you
um do you have a position on the bill so
we don't have an official position on
the bill other than we would are
concerned about the municipal portion
and as you debate and deliberate the
bill that you consider the potential
impacts um potentially if there was an
economic downturn or some major change
in our New Hampshire economy that could
impact the municipal rates because as I
explained um these dollars do go
directly to offsetting the tax rate and
they cannot be spent outside of the
budget or in addition to the budget
process much unlike our home checkbooks
what it our process works quite
differently um in
government thank you yes representa ORS
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so in your testimony if meals
and rooms tax goes up or down is there a
correlation as how much money comes into
our treasury or is it that it's
consistently going up no matter what
just it's the trend that people want to
eat out more whatever so currently um
under the law change in 2021 House Bill
2 changed the entire meals and rooms
formula so it used to be that the
legislature decided a set amount based
on what it felt that it could afford to
share back with cities and towns it was
statutorily set at 40% and it was waved
every single budget year um for decades
and it would range from 17 to 22% of
what was collected but it was a set
dollar amount under the new law change
we now receive 30% of what was actually
collected so as the funds are collected
every month the treasurer deposits them
into what a dedicated fund that was
created so if the state is doing better
we do better um if the state is is you
know which has not happened yet and I I
don't think it will let's hope then we
would receive less money and both of
those would have a direct impact as I
stated on the local tax property tax
right so if we receive less that that
less revenue is going to be um
potentially impacting our tax rate
because we anticipated more revenue and
most cities and towns use probably a
three to five year running average so
that they can conservatively estimate
going into the budget season so they're
not overestimating taxes and then it's
always a happy surprise and it is of
note that we set our budgets usually at
at this time of year right and
everything has to be set for our public
hearings in that February March time
frame some are a little bit later but we
don't find out our distribution amounts
until the tax rate is set in October so
we don't have a way there's no changes
that can be made once the budget is set
so typically again this really does go
to tax relief especially if we're
receiving additional funds which we have
been representative YY thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
you mentioned an economic downturn uh
reducing uh revenues uh the the amount
of money received by the towns and
cities under any scheme would go down in
an economic downturn because everything
is going down so the application of an
economic downturn or fear that's in air
quotes uh of an economic downturn
doesn't have any application because
it's going to happen regardless of the
system that takes place is that a
correct analysis I would say that
generally that's a correct statement but
in analyzing the two bills that we have
before us we know that if we were
already make a reduction to a the tax
contributing to it combined with an
economic downturn that would be
exacerbated but you are correct
representative representative fellows
thank you um
the charts that we're looking at in here
refer to M&R tax but it's really the
case that the tax that those two taxes
are not the same they're not the same
rate
and I was under the impression that the
the revenue raised from
rooms is now going to the education
trust fund is that not true is that the
way it was or is that the way it is now
or may maybe Dr should I I think Dr
should should answer that question
because I think there's some carve outs
on how that works I think there's a
percentage carve out and I don't want to
misrepresent any
statements and I have not time I haven't
had time to analyze the updated fiscal
information provided this
morning thank you thank you very
much and just for the note um Katherine
is from the nhma I don't know if you
mentioned that or not New Hampshire
Municipal
Association okay I have no other pink
cards on hb1 1422 is there anyone else
who wishes to speak on the
bill can I can I get an answer to that
question from Dr that's a good point um
distribution
question so so we have charts in in the
fiscal note talking about
M&R and the distribution of that and
we're talking about how much goes to
municipalities I I thought that I read
somewhere recently and I thought it was
from the budget that we passed that all
of the room tax is now going to the
education trust fund in the so going to
the education trust fund is the rentals
tax which we also call the vehicles
vehicle vehicle um that 100% goes to the
education trust fund so that's vehicle
rentals and it it is it yeah so the
rooms piece is what we would call the
occupancy and that stays in the general
fund before any additional carve outs to
the municipal Revenue fund and so forth
so that vehicle fund is it's not part of
room and meals it's this whole separate
tax um no it is part of the it is part
of the tax but that portion the way that
our tax form is set up we can identify
that and are then able to put that into
the education trust fund so there's
any other questions for
Dr okay thank you very much I'm going to
public
good okay I'm going to open the public
and uh later on representative Aly I
will need a pink card oh but I don't
need one right this minute thank you uh
so uh we'll start with representative
Aly to introduce the
Bill thank you
um this is uh representative Susan
Aly Grafton County city of
Lebanon um I am the prime sponsor of
house bill for 1492 relative to the rate
and exemptions of the interest and
dividends tax um I hadn't quite realized
because things have been very
messy uh so far this year on that
the
uh
the drafter stripped out my purpose
clause which was at the beginning of
this so to the extent that I can
remember um I want to tell you what that
this um the interest in dividends tax is
the only one that taxes a large number
of
retired um
citizens that are only receiving or
mostly re receiving interest in
dividends uh it is because of that and a
misconception that was conveyed to this
committee a long time ago that uh half
of the people paying the interest in
dividends tax are poor
elderly that on
WE avoided increasing the exemptions
over the
years uh but
the interest the the tax on those Rich
elderly of whom I know a fair number uh
that uh have especially the ones that
have moved into this state but also the
ones that are are living in retirement
without other income or without uh with
significant income from on interest
dividends and distribution
uh
that
we have um damn I'm I'm really tired
today
um that this is in Viola removing this
tax is in violation of our
constitution our constitution mentions
taxes twice the first time is in the
Bill of Rights at the beginning and and
it says that every citizen shall share
an equal burden of the cost of the
government services that all of us enjoy
whether you enjoy them or not uh but our
department of justice our department our
Department of
Transportation uh which is currently
trying to figure out what to do about
our roads uh and a lot of and the rest
of our government are important to all
of
us um unless you want to just sit in
your house every time it snows and never
go out um so the second place that it
mentions it is in the mechanics of
government in part two and in the Clause
that also includes the the adequate
education part uh it says that we can
impose those taxes that are reasonable
and
proportional uh now proportional means
equal rate we can only have one rate in
this state reasonable means exemptions
essentially uh it means that if the
person that you are taxing or the
business you are taxing would uh be
incapable of sustaining itself
um or rather a class of businesses would
be capable of sustaining
itself uh because you are taxing
it then we don't want to do that because
we are going to have to pay for the
person to go into the poor house and we
are going to no longer have that class
of businesses if we're taxing
it so by class at this point
interpreting it the way that we are not
supposed to to do this say um
cleaners of your
houses uh or of a
hospital uh lowly
paid on nurses lowly paid teachers lowly
paid um legal
assistance
uh there is a whole range of people
that we
pay money to to take care of things for
us and the money is insufficient to
their
livelihood the these people including
some in the middle
class uh I think of it as up to 40% of
our
population uh are not benefiting
from uh are are benefiting from parts
from taxation are paying taxes in
various
ways through
rent through um their tobacco
addiction um
through
uh on going to McDonald's to get a warm
meal once a day um
and they are part of our society we
cannot live without those
cleaners we cannot live
without uh a lot of the people that are
ass in assisting in
construction uh but that are paid lowly
enough that if we were taxing them we'd
have a
problem but what we do have is
have had is taxes a wide variety of
taxes that keep us from the government
from going
under um that have
been
created in order to provide enough money
to the government to keep the the
government
alive
and
the destruction of the interest in
dividends tax says that well really
wealthy people most if you look at the
chart that I passed out which I now I
didn't remember last night that I had
already printed it out I've now got
extra copies if anybody wants more um
but uh on the chart shows you that
most of the money of the interest in
dividends
tax has been coming from about 2,000
people in the state who
have over um
Investments
so they are capable of contributing to
our
society but it as we get rid of this
tax they will be scot-free
and fair number of them are people who
moved
here after their profitable
years and um and
settled so that is really
unconstitutional the other Factor in
$140,000 I mean sorry uh a million uh
$140 million doar in this
tax because the rich people in this
country have been increasing their
wealth relative to everybody else for
some
time and partly because of our tax
structure
nationally and
locally uh if if we get rid of this tax
they they will not the a lot of the
wealthiest people will no longer be
contributing um to what is left of our
government if you I'm not going to talk
about the other bill here but um
but we cannot
survive without the people at the lower
Spectrum we our hospitals will fall
apart uh everybody will have to start
taking of their care of their own houses
um there will not be a lot of people in
this
state
that uh like others that have gone
before them have decided to move out
because they cannot afford the property
tax in the
state
uh or to move away from our Urban
centers like
Lebanon because they cannot afford the
increasing property tax that is taking
care of the services in the outling
communities uh I've been home for 29
years now I think it is and I have
watched Lebanon lose its middle class
because of this on we have to remember
that there aren't just the rich people
here and the rich people can't live by
themselves they get a lot of help from
people that they
pay
so um that is why I am putting in a
reinstatement of the interest in
dividends tax but also be why I
completely on with the help of Dr
completely rewrote uh the interest in
dividends TX it was 100 years old last
year instead of building it um on re re
um revising it as they went along They
just added sections onto it it is pretty
difficult to read to figure out what you
have to do and there all there were also
things in it that are um not done
anymore they are archaic they have
disappeared and uh we verified that with
the Auditors uh before removing them
from from this
document um and I put on on everybody's
desks for your
enjoyment the um side by side which Dr
did for me uh the side by side of the
two of the old tax and the new tax so
that you can see where everything moved
to and from what got
deleted and completely and on the one
section
that is in common with the previous bill
that we
ited uh last week
um that um triples the exemptions to the
interest in dividends tax because as far
as I can tell it's been at least 40
years since we increased those
exemptions and the tripling actually
doesn't quite do it but I'm not really
sure about what the date that they they
changed it
so uh tripling the
exemptions I figured out from the
triangles and it probably is wrong but
um it's in the fiscal note that we got
um I believe except that they didn't say
how much is coming off uh but I I think
it's about $5
about about 30 million not 30 million
30,000 people that really should not be
paying that have been paying or in the
case of half of them have been reporting
that they don't have to pay anything
um for years now because we had not
increased the exemptions the way we have
been learning to increase the uh
exemptions for business profits business
Enterprise and so forth um for the
businesses and which does keep the small
businesses that have been talked about
uh otherwise um out of the equation of
thing I wanted to bring forward
was what happened in
December in
December the our business
taxes filed they were supposed to file
for um
$13.5 million uh dollar of business
profits and business Enterprise tax
according to our plan for the first time
they went below
plan
uh half of of that below was apparently
um
the our attempt in this committee to
remove um the huge amount of surplus
taxes that are sitting in the treasury
uh that are not being used and that we
might lose any day if their businesses
come and say we need that many because
we're in the recession now um so uh
that's yet another issue that gets
complicating things
but we are below plan by 99.6% and the
plan did include looking at those refund
possibilities um
so this is the first time we don't know
if it's going to continue from now
through the end of this fiscal year but
we have made a lot of changes cuts and
structural changes to the business
taxes and
um there are
possibilities and probabilities that
those are going to have a negative
effect on our business tax revenues the
business tax revenues are a
structure and I would very much like to
know from anybody that wants to keep
cutting what you think we're going to
cut out of state government and as it
stands so
um I
think oh no um the last one that I I
gave you besides the Dr
material uh is
um
the is
a document that was written by Phil slon
for this bill about the history of rates
and file file
thresholds which I haven't had a chance
to read yet
myself on and he gave it to me this
morning and said he has a meeting at
10:00 so he wouldn't be able to be
here
so um that I think is also worth reading
Phil slon is a was a very good auditor
and he is a very good
nonprofit uh so I'm not sure if he's
ever going to be submitting
to um to an economics
paper but maybe he should be doing that
at this point so that you people can no
longer say that it hasn't been been um
so
so um that's I don't want to go any
further on this I probably could but
thank you I'm sure we'll have uh we'll
be discussing this quite a bit in work
session as well um it looks like we may
have a question for you uh
representative
ulery thank you
Mr thank you
s the section of the Constitution that
you quote also contains the phrases for
specific
uses and further down it also says that
if the taxpayer the citizen the resident
of of New Hampshire if they don't get
anything from they have no obligation
to there has to be an
equivalency I pay for taxes I get a for
On The Border to protect me from Indians
at the
time you know for number
four um just as an example the
equivalency
today would
be
what the the equivalency today is
totally
impossible and I may not
need a
court uh that is going to listen to me
in neutral fashion and um uh agree that
I'm being prosecuted for wrongly right
now uh but I may need it
later or I may have needed it
earlier on but that Court protects me
from a whole lot of things as does the
Attorney General's office as do um the
police on the street who are trying to
keep
keep somebody from robbing me or killing
me on the
street
uh
and government has changed an awful lot
over the
centuries I do not believe in the form
of originalism that the Supreme Court
seems to be trying to imply now but you
cannot equate for
instance a AK-47 or whatever it is with
a
load should we discuss this during work
session instead or do you have a
build works thank you sir any other
questions thank you
and if you could fill out a pink card
representative Aly that would be
great um Greg Moore I don't think he's
here he filled out a card I think he's
he had to go somewhere
else uh next up we have
bramy thank you Mr chair and uh hello to
everybody good to always good to be back
uh I was former uh ways of means member
for 12 years I've I've testified here
before but I'm actually here
representing the granite state taxpayer
Group which is a group that was founded
decades ago by meldam Thompson Governor
Thompson um before I get going um uh
Representatives fellows I haven't had
the the uh the uh Revenue Focus from uh
this last month the uh rman meals
tax uh for Education was 5.5 million as
compared to 175 million Revenue so I
just want to point that's a very small
part of the
total from so yes you're right that 5.5
does go to something else it goes to
education but okay
so
um I'm here I was here when we first put
a plan in place to to reduce and
eliminate the interest in dividends tax
and I'm not a I'm not a as a legislator
I was never a a just reduce reduce
reduce kind of guy I always wanted to do
it in a on a phased way based on what we
thought revenues were going to
be um and even the way the phase out was
it was over a fiveyear period making it
it's always a good thing to phas things
in just in
case and the reason we did that back
then was back in 21 fiscal
21 uh our our total revenues increased
were above plan by
11.6% and then when we went to fiscal
22's revenues that increased another $
264.7
million and most of that was business
taxes uh in fiscal 21 the the plan was
for
$786 million of business tax but we
actually had we wand up with
$991 point4 million in in tax or a
difference of
$25
million but then when we go to the next
fiscal year that went up another
$22.8
million
so we talked for years about we don't
have an income tax and then people who
moved here
would say wait a minute I'm getting
taxed on I'm getting taxed on my
interest in dividends isn't that income
well it's income but not not earned
income it's income from dividends and
interest so we thought at the time this
was a good idea let's do it now because
all these other revenues are so strong
this is the time to to make the move uh
and that's what we did then after I left
the legisl
I guess it was last year where we
accelerated that and uh to uh be done by
the end of this year right now it's
three well last year was 4% this year
it's 3% and by uh January 1 of uh next
year it'll be
zero now as far as unconstitutionality s
representative Aly I mean you also said
this this tax has been around for 100
years boy you think someone would have
figured that one out by now
uh so I mean it's it's I don't think
it's
unconstitutional uh so I don't know if I
I agree with that that
argument and the other thing about all
of our revenues and I'm going to talk in
a minute about where we are this this
fiscal year uh but remember that in the
budget the Senate increased revenues
from this committee a lot more but they
based the budget on something a lot less
that there's a lot of surplus in that
budget uh that they that we all both
party both House and Senate uh agreed to
so
um so here's my six points I got six
points real quick uh again my first one
I already mentioned for years people
thought there was
no uh income tax uh people were shocked
to find out that there was an interest
in dividends tax and we made the move
because we were in a fiscal position to
do
so uh
but people of financial means were
moving here most of those would know
that there that there was an interest in
dividends
tax uh but the fact that we're removing
that is now making them more willing and
spurring on them to move to New
Hampshire uh and guess what they spend
that money here the people of means will
be spending that money here uh which
will eventually wind its way into
business
uh and then then my next point is simple
one uh representa mami's point is that
uh it's a philosophical
difference she she feels that the upper
the upper income from inition dividends
people should pay more than the lower
rung uh of
income uh but that's a philosophical
difference um I think I think that uh if
we're going to eliminate it let's
eliminate it let's not keep on even
though she feels the tax is
unconstitutional we're still going to
have tears we're still at some point uh
it's not an equal it's not it will not
be an equal
tax so uh the fourth point is
uh remember that businesses also play
the interest in dividends tax and by
eliminating the interest in dividends
tax yes the because they have
Investments so businesses also pay that
tax and uh they invest their money um
and by eliminating it to me it's just an
another component of creating a business
friendly environment in New Hampshire
and we did that by reducing the the uh
in a very rational way over many years
reducing business taxes here and uh and
and the proofs in the Ping by the big
jump that we've seen in interest in
dividends now I know I saw the slon
article to and we talked about that in
the gr State taxpayer group and no one
in that group agrees with that article
nobody just just to make that point and
I know we know him I know him very well
because he comes here every year and
testifies uh during budget
time so the the the fifth
point and I think
represent Army Point pointed this out
that they there's you could say there's
a slight slowing in in revenues and
business
taxes um it was that 9.6 million I think
yes it's for last month but business
taxes are still 36.8 million above
Target and again a very inflated
Target uh uh so I I would say uh it's
fine it's just one
month but and and then and she was
pointing out rightfully so and if you
read your Revenue Focus they describe
what happened in the first six months
because we we we had the credit carry
forward Bill uh that we dealt with a
couple years ago where we said because
the amount of credits that were out
there by
individuals was significant and if
everybody asked for a refund on one year
we wouldn't have the money to do it it
so we are now forcing individuals I
think it's I forget the total it's it's
in the report it's 500 something
uh that
we that we're forcing them to to give
back some of to actually for us to give
them back money we are refunding people
at a higher rate because we're forcing
them to accept that we're not we're not
allowing them to keep that money uh as
we were unlimited before more and that
that that's going to go down a little
bit more each
year so of the
89 this year so far TW first 12 12 uh
six months the refunds were $ 89.8
million uh as compared to last fiscal
year at the same time of 45.2 million so
those refunds have doubl so yes that
would have and a lot of that would
impact in December as people are getting
uh as the year as the calendar year was
was ending uh but uh but so that's one
of the reasons why there's a slight
taxes and then my final my final point
is most people celebrated the fact that
the interest in I I didn't meet one
person of even less of my means who who
didn't think that getting rid of the
intive attack the give in tax was a good
idea uh and and again this is one of
those perception things by the public we
as a legislature said we were going to
do this the governor signed the bill we
were phasing it out and now we're going
to reverse that we're going to we're
going to put it back in starting next
year I know that the that the uh
exemptions are a lot higher and all of
that uh but I just still think it's a
bad look for us to reverse course on
this especially what the other revenues
still
doing quite well so that's that's my
testimony and I I appreciate the time
thank you any question yes
representative fellows has a question
thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question um I've heard other
people make the same comment that you
did that
by eliminating this tax more very
wealthy people who get income from
interest and dividends will move to New
Hampshire right and I'm just wondering
if you have any proof of that
because my assumption if you know my
guess as to you know why somebody would
move to New Hampshire if they're very
wealthy and and didn't have any other
reason to pick New Hampshire over
something else that it would be because
they're trying to avoid just a general
income tax well yeah I mean let's look
at Massachusetts they put a millionaires
tax in place what happened they're
fleeing they're losing tax revenue
California who taxes everything
California people are fleeing California
because they keep on increasing those
taxes and uh and and people are going to
go they're moving they're voting with
their
feet uh and we want to make it
attractive to them to come over here to
us um because
you know again these are all
philosophical things I mean I I
personally believe that if you attract
and make this a good business climate
businesses will come we've proven that
they have come despite what Sutton has
to
say um and I think individuals make
those same and it just happens that
people are more flexible to move when
they're retired because they don't have
to worry about where they make their
income but we'll take that money when
they come here they're gonna they're
going to spend that money here they're
gonna they're gonna they're going to
hire The Gardener they're going to hire
the whatever and uh uh you know and
everybody everybody gets good paying
jobs I mean I I uh especially in
business when they when they come
because a lot of these businesses that
come
here uh do create I mean we're talking
bigger businesses make good good
salaries and in terms of uh the fact is
that there's such a shortage of
workers we're seeing that without
without raising our minimum wage
we're I mean we're seeing we're seeing
people making a lot more money than ever
before at lower paying jobs I mean you
can make if you can't make $20 an hour
now um there's something wrong with you
I mean they're they're everywhere I mean
I uh you you uh but anyway I I don't
thing yes representative shamber thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my Qui question The Honorable
Representative Patrick
aramy uh you mentioned that you said
remember businesses pay interest in
dividend yeah who do they pay it
to they pay to the state no no they pay
they don't pay any to their shareholders
or anything like that
or no this is this is on this isn't yes
they pay interest divid in city of
sharehold the different interest in
dividends different dividends this is
they invest they have they have money in
the bank okay but they're not they're
not and they have some some companies
have a lot of money in the bank okay and
that that's creating those kind of
interest and dividends okay thank you
followup follow up will you take a
followup oh yeah okay thank you for you
you've always wanted to talk I know
you've always wanted to talk about
things uh the uh uh interest and
dividends at the businesses play pay uh
are they supporting the marketplace
structures that we have in place in this
state that
money the the marketplace you know like
roads Emergency Services uh um education
housing well businesses they pay they
pay uh they pay property taxes as well
so they're education on property tax I'm
on interest and
dividends what about it okay no no no I
mean the interest in
dividends that they obviously they pay
shareholders that's a different kind of
Interest dividends which is good because
those investors have reinvest that money
and they buy things so that's a positive
thing but the interest in dividends that
they make no it's there but they you
know what they do with that they they
they you have you have profits you keep
some in the bank what do you spend that
money on eventually
you on increased you you you're going to
build a new building you're going to
build a new plant that's what it goes to
and that all creates new jobs therefore
more wealth for the state as well as the
country so it's it's it's basic
economics I mean
uh I'll leave it at that one last
followup okay I think um we're starting
to have a philosophical issue which we
can have again in the work session you
mentioned that
there were a lot of people moving from
certain States uh because of taxes uh do
you sure they're not moving here because
of our great environment our clean water
our clean air our land over the economic
conditions of course it's multiple
factors thank you I just want to make
sure yeah
yeah thank you any other questions
seeing not oh represent fellows I would
thank you I would like to just follow up
on on the your comments about that
businesses are paying part of this
interest in dividends um when I look at
this chart you know from Dr uh I see do
you by dis by businesses do you mean
Partnerships that are listed on here
there's about a thousand of
them is that what you mean by businesses
because I don't think they fall into the
individual Partnerships have money in
the bank Partnerships will have money in
the
bank uh and they you call them they have
to pay they have to pay interest and
dividends on that money like everybody
else yeah if I can pay interest in
dividends tax on that anybody whether
your business in a business account or
if it's a personal account if I if I
have money in the bank I I have to pay
interest in dividends on it I have to
pay interest on it or if I have it
invested in a in in a stock portfolio I
have to pay div dividends when I get
dividends on it so businesses do that as
a corporation they have to pay interest
in dividends individ Partnerships those
guys have Partners I mean I I was an
esort my business we we talked about
that last year um that uh we paid
interest in dividends taxes uh because
we had money in the bank and we we
weren't going to just put on our pillow
so we we had to pay let's just say we St
in the bank we had to pay interest in
dividend tax on the in interest that we
received thank you
yeah I mean pretty much any entity
whether that entity is an individual an
S corporation a C corporation a
partnership whatever it is to uh former
representative um obam's point is any
entity that's getting money through a
bank interest stock dividends whatever
they have to pay the interest in
dividends tax so oh well in that case
can you tell tell me why
they're why it's not listed on
here well I can't speak to why it's not
listed there but we we Dr is coming up
at the end of these I still have uh four
more people to speak so hold that
thought and uh seeing no more questions
thank you representative thank you that
Hall
thank you Mr chairman I have U prepared
the thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um I pay the New Hampshire
interest in dividends tax in fact
I if you could just introduce yourself
yes I live in Chichester New Hampshire
I'm here representing myself I was um a
member of this General Court back about
30 plus years ago
um and I'm here just testifying on my
own
behalf uh and bringing some information
to you that you may not uh have heard
before uh I paid my last quarterly
estimate this morning on the interest
and dividends tax for last year so uh
I'm familiar with it uh I've come to
support passage of
1492 and what I want to do is present to
you a little bit of history and
comparison on June 12th
1784 10 days after the current state
constit tion took
effect the New Hampshire legislature
passed its first law regarding
taxation the Preamble of that law stated
quote whereas it is necessary that there
should be an equitable rule established
by law for making rates and taxes within
this state so that every person may be
compelled to pay in proportion to his
income and then went on to establish
various
taxes the real estate tax a business
profits tax and a tax on investments
were all part of that law of
1784 money at interest improved in trade
or in stock was taxed at half of
1% that tax was on the asset itself not
on the income It produced
boost the taxation of money deposited in
banks or loan to others for interest or
profit evolved over the 19th century
into the state interest and tax law
interest and dividends tax law that we
have known for many many
decades the tax proposed in this bill
like the current law is based on the
resulting earnings not on the asset
itself so let me do a little math for a
comparison for
you under this bill for a couple today
with a million dollars of Investments
and perhaps earning
5% the interest in dividends tax would
be 50 the interest in dividends earn
would be $50,000 of which
15,000 would be exempt for the couple
and the 5% tax on the remaining
$35,000 of earned interest in dividends
$1,750 that's what this bill would
produce under those conditions if the
original 1784 law were in effect with
its rate of 1 half% of the assets
$5,000 about three times as much as this
bill would propose
I just want you to reflect on that as
you consider House Bill
1492 that tax on assets has a long
history in this
state and I know that there are
certainly people who would like to Red
reduce taxes and I imagine as each of
you ran for office you had quite a few
conversations with your constituents
about
taxes but I would also bet that the tax
they were most concerned about was the
property tax not the interest in
dividends tax so I have a suggestion for
you in this bill Dr is to deposit the
proceeds I suggest it be amended to have
those proceeds be deposited in the
education trust fund to do that would
result in an equal amount of property
tax reduction throughout the state
so instead of reducing the interest in
dividends tax put it back to the 5% put
it all in the education trust fund just
like the car rental tax is and you'll be
providing property tax relief of about
$100 million a year thank you thank you
any
questions yes represent ORS thank you Mr
chair and welcome honorable Doug Hall
it's good to see you here
so you had mentioned the uh the tax the
current uh the way you work this formula
out saying that the insuring dividends
would be 50,000 which 15,000 would be
exempt is that something written into
the current tax code I assume no that's
in the bill okay it's in the
bill all right thank you very
much
kleene hi Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for having me I'm
Drew Klein and president of the jiah
barlot Center for Public Policy we're
New Hampshire's free market Think Tank
um our view on this bill starts with the
fact that New Hampshire has uh had an
income tax now for a long time that's
the interest dividends tax and it is in
fact an income tax it is um written in
the state law as an income tax that's
the actual language used in the state
law uh the Department of Revenue
Administration calls it an income tax
and hp1 1492 calls it an income tax so
New Hampshire does in fact have an
income tax it's on passive income earned
through interest
dividends and that expires at the end of
this year which will make when that
happens New Hampshire the only state in
the Northeast without an income
tax it would make New Hampshire to my
knowledge the eighth State without an
income tax some people say seventh I
think it's eighth um we would be the
Northeast United States is the only
region of the five regions in the
country that does not have a single
state without an income tax so if you go
to the southeast the Southwest the
Midwest West the the Northwest they all
tax the closest state with no income tax
to New Hampshire is Tennessee which just
got rid of its version of the interest
and dividend tax a couple years
ago what we've seen in the
last several years is a um rapidly
increased increasing level of
competition among the states for people
and for business businesses for
investment for
entrepreneurship um just from if I get
the numbers right off the top of my head
um and I can go back and look this up
for you but I believe it was you know 21
through
22 going into um the first part of 2023
just look at that you know roughly two
years there uh 22 States cut taxes um
only a couple have increased taxes and
they're doing this because they're
competing very aggressively for
residents and all we have to do is look
at Massachusetts to see how much it
means to tax or not tax higher income
residents it's Pioneer Institute which
is sort of our counterpart down there
it's the think tank in
Massachusetts they looked at out
migration from Massachusetts and it's
really rather stunning before the
millionaires tax happened from 2019 to
2021 the top four states are net out
migration of wealth and we're looking
at the total amount of wealth that
leaves the state when people leave we're
California New York Illinois and
Massachusetts in 2019 net out migration
of adjusted gross income from
Massachusetts was just over 900 million
but by 2021 it was 4.3
billion that is high net worth higher
income individuals fleeing Massachusetts
that was before the millionaires tax
that was put in place in 2022 2 took
effect in 2023 and you saw um an
immediate spike in high income High net
worth individuals moving to New
Hampshire New Hampshire Business Review
reported this reported this in a story
in early 2023 it's been reported in lots
of business Publications around the
region the uh Massachusetts Association
of certified public
accountants surveyed their own members
and that their members saw a gigantic
spike in requests from their
clients on how to move to New
Hampshire they wanted help in looking
for homes in New Hampshire they wanted
to flee
Massachusetts the top two destinations
for people leaving
Massachusetts are New Hampshire and
Florida what of those two states have in
common they do not have an income tax
une earned income
uh
Florida is competing very aggressively
with New Hampshire to be the the Free
State uh in the United States we are
losing in New Hampshire residents uh
retirees from New Hampshire who are
moving to Florida partly because of the
weather and partly because it does not
have a tax on unearned income they have
no income tax in Florida they have a
sales tax but they do not have a tax on
interest dividend
income
when you see that people fleeing
Massachusetts pick as their top two
destinations Florida and New Hampshire
not Connecticut in New Hampshire not
Maine in New Hampshire not Vermont in
New Hampshire that tells you something
very important they the only state in
the Northeast without any income tax
that will be a powerful recruiting tool
marketing tool Economic Development
tool um but that will not happen if we
reinstate the income tax in New
Hampshire
so from our point of view at the ji
Bartlet Center we work on economic
growth issues we work on uh State
competitiveness issues and we talked to
a lot of think tanks around the country
and we can see this movement happening
you see it in Census Data you see it in
Moving company data or people tend to
move um there are factors not everybody
makes the decision purely on financial
reasons but when you hold all other
factors um into account and you account
for weather and you account for job
opportunities Etc um low taxes is a
serious um and Powerful motivating
factor for where people migrate from and
so this bill would make New Hampshire
much less competitive and much less
attractive to people who would look to
move in here but it also would continue
pushing people out of New Hampshire and
that's something that we it's not just
that we would attract people to move in
we do now have people leaving the state
because of this tax so from our point of
view that would be a negative um overall
effect on this on the
state thank you yes
YY thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking uh my question Mr sure um a
couple of questions the first
one would you say or would you agree
that the middle class in the United
States under under the current economic
situation is running between $200 and
$300,000 per year for married couple I
would really hate to define those terms
um I think that's dependent on a lot of
your own personal and family situation
of whether you view yourself middle
class or not um so I I would hate to say
but I think it's fair to say that um
most people who earn in that range would
consider themselves middle class and not
wealthy and follow up follow up so as we
in reading this particular bill it
appears as
though the base of the um or the the
body of those eligible for taxation
would be expanded even though there was
there are increases in um exemptions and
deductions and you know a bunch
of ply stuff messing around with it but
it would seem as though the the body
would be EXP exped well into the middle
class which would then to
me seem to be attacking and retarding
the growth of upward mobility of
individuals is that a fair analysis in
your opinion well I mean I don't know
that i' get
into sort of trying to Define with
Precision who would pay this tax under
here I think it's a little complicated
um maybe the Dr can have a little bit
bit more of a say on that but as I look
at it um and looking at the interest and
dividends income tax right now um it is
simply not true that uh the the sort of
perception of this is a tax that only
the super wealthy pay I mean when you
look now at who pays the interest and
dividends tax I mean when you look at
the dr's own numbers um you know 41% of
those who pay the interest dividends tax
only pay between $100 and
$500 in the tax that's after the
deduction now the deduction increase in
The Spill will shift that burden more
towards uh higher income individuals but
it is just not the case now and it
wouldn't be the case in the future that
this would only affect you know super
wealthy people uh folks who have put
away a sizable amount of money and H to
grow that investment income would be hit
by this tax and the the other thing to
sort of keep in mind is that when you
have an income tax on the book even if
if you create those exemptions and carve
outs and you try to skew it to the super
wealthy the fact is you still have an
income tax on the books and when you are
talking about attracting people look
more and more people
now are trying to make their money
through Investments um people are
getting a lot more Savvy about how to
make passive income that this is a path
to a secure future um so it is
detrimental to New Hampshire in the long
term in terms of attracting people from
outside but also keeping people here who
want to build up that nest egg over time
you don't normally just all of a sudden
have a million dollars in the bank you
grow that over time you start small and
grow at large and so when you're looking
at a state that has an income tax on
that investment
income versus a state that
doesn't you're going to start to weigh
those calculations and you know I I
respect Doug Hall very much
um in
1784 most people never ventured more
than 20 miles from their home we live in
a much different competitive economic
world that we do today people can
literally choose to live anywhere in the
world they want and New Hampshire needs
to make sure it's attractive to families
that want to build wealth um and having
an income tax on the books is going to
make us somewhat less attractive to
those
folks yes represent shamber thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr coin for
taking my question here uh you mentioned
the word detrimental how is it
detrimental to New Hampshire to support
your
community um I as a total nonse with a
question
sir
agreed any other questions seeing none
thank you thank
you
okay
um I don't know if I'm going to
pronounce this correctly but next we
have
Roy
schwier and you can let me know how
close I came with pronouncing your name
correctly thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I am Roy schwier that
is the correct pronunciation according
to the German language and I'm from
conquer and I'd like to say I think this
proposed tax is kind of like about the
most unfair tax you could devise and I
have three reasons for that number one
is if somebody has a pencil they can
write down this question for me when the
Dr comes up what percentage of the
interest in dividends tax is paid by
people over 65 they know that because
the check box on the form is compared to
what percentage of the total income in
the state is earned by people over 65 I
think you'll find that this tax is you
know
far heavier on retired people and that's
particularly interesting because if
we're talking about putting that the in
the education trust fund retired people
are probably far less than people in
other age groups to have kids in schools
and as far as what representative Aly
said about it being unconstitutional not
to have this tax I'm going to ask why is
it unconstitutional to not tax interest
in dividends but it's okay to not
tax earned income
wages and if you think this tax is to
soak the rich instead of you know going
after people interest in dividends why
not have an income tax on everybody with
$100,000 a year exemption I mean that
way you'd really get people with money
and you wouldn't be you know going after
people that may or may not be making
good money like right now if I have
$8,000 in interest and dividend income I
would have to pay this tax if I have
$100,000 salary I have to pay nothing
and that is you know fair for our share
of the state expenses the second thing
has to do with what we'll call inflation
that's been very low for a long time and
people haven't thought about it but it
really eats up over the years on people
I think I figured out one time that I
the money I have now was worth 17th of
what it was when I first started earning
and I've always felt it was really nasty
the federal government I mean they're
the ones that could stop inflation they
allow inflation to exist and then when
there's inflation they tax you more the
more inflation there is based on the
income tax on your interest I don't
think there's anybody in this state that
has Bank interest that pays even as much
as the inflation rate I think unless you
you know earn a credit card company or
or a loone shark the interest you earn
is less than the inflation so in fact
you're kicking people when they're down
if you're charging a tax on Bank
interest because I in effect have less
purchasing power at the end of the year
and the state is still taxing me on the
fact I'm getting less purchasing power
and my last
item has to do with the the people who
are even older when I started working in
1972 full-time you the IAS didn't exist
401ks didn't exist 401ks didn't be
become popular until 1981 which is nine
years after I started working so when I
had to start putting money aside the
only thing I could do is put it in
regular you know bank accounts and
stocks and so forth so in
effect if someone put puts their money
in a
401k they don't get taxed when they take
it out by the state but because I put my
money in a savings account or a stock I
wind up having to pay tax on the income
from that whereas I wouldn't have had to
pay tax on the income from the 401K so
particularly older folks and some of you
may be among
them you know you have years when you're
putting money away and you couldn't you
know get a tax exemption of and I'm
still pay paying the interest on it so I
think that uh you know thinking about
not just people over 65 but people over
you know whatever since 1981 people that
you know became a wage earners before
then need to have some special deal for
the fact that they're getting taxed on
their retirement money whereas younger
people that have a 401k aren't and the
last thing I'm going to mention is I
haven't got all my statements this year
for interest I've earned and two weeks
ago I went to the
uh Revenue Administration to get tax
warrants for this year oh we don't have
those yet you can get them off the
internet well if I don't have internet
at home that makes it hard to get forms
off the internet I should be able to get
them when I go to the Dr so you might
ask them why tax warrants for this year
weren't available December 1st so I
could take my tax forms and take my
interest statements and figure out
whether I should pay estimated tax or
not because my concern is the interest
I'm getting this year is a lot higher
percentage than it was two or three
years ago I'm asked have to be paid
paying more interest dividends tax than
I was previously even though it's all
phony money I'm losing money on that and
I'm still paying a lot of tax on it so
thank you thank you for your testimony
sir okay and last uh lastly I'll ask
Loreno Sullivan and Keen Wong to come up
and um see if we have any questions for
you
[Music]
well good afternoon I'm laureno Sullivan
Dr good afternoon this is Keen M Wong
tax policy council with the Dr thank you
do we have any qu I should have asked if
there were any questions before we had
you have to walk up but does does anyone
have any
questions thank you for coming back up I
you I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone else who would like to
testify on HB 1492 before I close the
public
hearing seeing none I will close the
now we do have three more bills um and
um I know last time we skipped lunch and
we didn't finish till about quarter a
three however these three bills may go
quickly I'm thinking what we will do is
we'll start with the first one we'll
kind of see how it goes and if it takes
longer than expected we'll take a lunch
break um I my my thought is right now
that these three are
very related and and very fairly very
straightforward so we may be able to get
see okay I will open the hearing on hb1
1531 and recognize representative ulery
to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chair my name is
Jordan oler Hillsboro 13 town of Hudson
and uh I'm introducing HB
1531 relative to allowing business
profits tax adjustment for the
depreciation deduction permitted under
the uh Internal Revenue code section 168
paragraph
K all this does is bring allows uh New
Hampshire businesses to take advantage
of existing federal law I believe this
was recommended by d uh to some degree
to allow some compatibility between the
uh two different tax structures and make
their job easier and make it easier for
businesses in New
Hampshire okay I think on this one we
probably will end up having them uh give
us more detail does anyone have any
questions of Representative illery good
no okay he's relieved thank
you all right um
I don't have any other pink cards um is
there anyone else who wants to testify
um to work session Dr No I'm going to
time
good afternoon Kong tax policy council
with the
Dr Lauren O Sullivan senior financial
analyst
Dr
questions representative Aly thank you
could
you explain on I think what this says is
that we're going to give a greater
upfront deduction for new property than
do uh that is correct so um essentially
this 168k is a like a a bonus
depreciation um and it essentially
accelerates those depreciation deduction
for certain qualified assets uh at the
uh in the year where the property was
placed into service and then once that's
done the the remainder of the uh the uh
depreciation allowable depreciation will
be claimed over the useful life of the
asset so essentially instead of um let
say an asset has a 20-year useful life
which is normally claimed over the 20
years uh this provision allows initial
part of the uh the claim to be made in
the first year whereas um the
the that's how it normally works but
then with the with the
tcja the 100% of the um expense or 100%
of the cost actually allowed on the
first
starting starting 2023 onwards that um
that 100% reduces to to 80% and then 60%
and so on and so forth until 2027 it
becomes zero um this bill um removes all
100% essentially there is a there is a
limit it's 100% but there is a limit
correct it's up to
500,000
[Music]
um because I know on H um another bill
will'll be talking about HB 1536
yeah deals with the limit yeah that one
is the uh the 179 deduction so that one
has that limit this one is the 168k um
bonus depreciation uh it does not have
that limit um so essentially it's a
timing if everything else remains equal
is essentially a timing difference um
likely where uh a business organization
is able to claim upfront the first year
that they plac the uh asset into service
100% of the expense versus cling over
the 20 years or whatever useful life of
the asset but is there a limit on on
that number uh no I don't believe
there's a limit for this one the the 179
there was there's a limit on the 179
expense it's also a a first year
deduction on the expense okay yes
represent thank you follow up and were
we doing this
before um
no uh we the current law is that we do
depreciation
so follow up follow up so if
the on company which builds industrial
wire in um I can never remember it's not
in Bristol it's it's closer to it in
Grafton County on which is a very large
company on decides to totally replace a
$50
million uh cyclotron or
something uh that it's
using
um and its
tax rate its tax goes down to Zero
year but then would
we if it was only 2 million that year
and they had 50 million I'm just picking
on them because I'm really impressed by
them on and it goes down to to two
million uh they only can take two
million but of the 50 million do they
keep then taking it off every year until
the 50 million is
exhausted so if that uh that business
organization had that qualifying asset
um and if only 2 million of that
qualifying asset uh sorry has qualifying
assets and only 2 million of those
assets are qualifying assets for the uh
for this deduction yes then they would
um take that deduction in the year that
they would place in service and then the
the other assets that were not
qualifying assets they would be um
depreciated over the useful life of the
asset so I'm sorry uh I guess I'm just
really tired but on I I'm not sure he
understood the question okay it sounds
to me what she's saying is if the
business only had a certain amount you
know they can only take a certain amount
because their income is only a certain
level and they have to continue that
depreciation in another year is it
allowed
to
oh um forget the or is it only a onee
thing uh if I'm not mistaken um but I
just need to double check this but not
mistaken there there uh there's no
income sort of a limitation to that so
even though if if the uh the business
organization um has that only a certain
amount of taxable income the
depreciation that would be able to be
claimed under the 168k will be whatever
that's fully allowed in that one year um
and it potentially could generate a net
operating loss situation and then carry
over the net operating loss over
oh and that one is kept at 10 yes that's
right million yeah so the most we'd lose
million y um actually uh representative
shamberg um I think I I got Clarity on
on the whole idea of testifying being on
a bill and asking questions and the
choice is you either testify on the bill
or you can ask questions so if you're
sitting back there because you think you
you you can
actually but you can sit here you can
sit
here that's
fine okay I just because that was
something that that needed clarification
from
from last week um I told representative
ORS that he couldn't ask questions um it
turns out after checking with the clerk
he can because even if you're a
co-sponsor you have a choice you're
either testifying or you can stay back
um at your seat and ask questions you
can't do both um so representative PL
yes would you please explain to me the
appreciation under Section 168 of the
Internal Revenue code is that
depreciation of any asset you place in
assets so the uh the bonus depreciation
only applies to depreciation uh
depreciable assets with a recovery per
period of 20 years or
less um so essentially it would be
Vehicles furniture manufacturing
equipment heavy machinery uh but not
buildings
yeah it's representing
fellows so that that is also my question
like what are the things the qualifying
things so you know you just said is it
like any piece of equipment any vehicle
I I mean there are a lot of you know I
know the dep normal
I don't I don't know the tax law but I
know I have an idea about like just
regular Accounting in different you know
you depreciate a computer over maybe
three years and a vehicle over maybe
three years but some other pieces of
equipment would be
longer so is there something special
about this these
qualifying um assets compared to just
normal accounting so I I believe um the
purpose behind the um this 168k
originally from from the federal side of
things is to
stimulate um growth and therefore they I
speculate that that's the reason why
they would um have this qualifying
assets up to the uh 20 years useful life
um
yeah so it is a something from the
federal side it's not something that
Dr so that that was um put in during the
tcja and that is phasing out correct
that is correct yep and so this would
this would allow New Hampshire to be um
favorable to business investment and
potentially attract uh more business
here the uh the the the the bonus
depreciation essentially actually it was
enacted prior to tcj but then it has a
like a I think 50% depreciation uh
deduction allowable during tcja um the
federal government increased that to
100% with the uh with the phase outs
over the number of
years um do we have any knowledge on um
surrounding states and how they're
handling this whether they're allowing
this or there's some limit to it um my
apologies no I not looked to that yeah
okay is that something we could get
information on or yeah we'll try to uh
we can try to research that and see if
we can come up with some information on
that okay thank you I think that would
be that would be helpful to know yes
representative fellows so I mean maybe
you could um it would be helpful if I
had something to read about what
happened at the federal level that
created this you know program or I don't
know what to call it you know that and
why they did that were they trying to
like stimulate the economy and and is is
it staying on the federal books or is
that coming off the federal books it's
coming off in 2027 at 0% 20127 yes and
then what if we pass this bill I'm sorry
followup okay followup follow so and so
if we pass this bill then would it would
it we be giving taking that off the book
in 2027
100% thank you I I would just like if
you can give me like a little one page
description of the federal program that
you yes represent BR thank you Mr
chairman and just so I understand this I
think I heard this from the co-sponsor
introduced the bill so I can fully
understand and I think I do but if I'm
hearing this correctly this will allow
New
Hampshire businesses uh to ultimately
get into like a cost segregation study
where we can depreciate different assets
of an
overall project at a different rate so
that you know the building might might
be depreciated at 392 years but by with
this bill we could depreciate the air
conditioning system at 15 years the roof
at 20 years is that is I understanding
that properly that this actually will
allow businesses in New Hampshire to do
what they're doing federally to do it on
a state
level uh I believe that is correct
because on the on the federal side um I
think business organizations are
encouraged to perform a cost segregation
analysis so so that they can uh
substantiate what asset is a qualifying
asset versus what asset is not a
qualifying asset for the IRS to allow
the uh the deduction um
yeah follow up follow up yes thank you
Mr J and then just as far as the federal
law that you talk about 2
2027 isn't do don't they gener the feds
generally extend that law every every
time you I mean that's usually the drama
that leads up to uh taxes and whether or
not they're going to extend that is that
am am I right in
that uh I I can't I can't speculate on
on that on what the federal government
is going to do um it's it's 20 right now
0% yes represent
um what what percentage did we allow
before the TG well we haven't done we we
haven't gone with the TG
G that law uh on so what percentage are
we currently allowing them to deduct at
the
beginning we currently do not allow um
the the bonus
depreciation oh at all at all yes so you
just deduct
a percentage each year for the yes so
whatever uh whatever bonus depreciation
that the business has taken federally it
would be added back on the New Hampshire
side and then they the the business
organization would depreciate that
regularly yeah well excuse follow up y
follow up could uh could you give
us what businesses are permitted under
168k
because if we're allowing all businesses
to do
this and they all started doing it in
trouble I might be mistaken but I
believe it's all businesses um there
might be an exception but then the
essential driver is the um the asset
with the uh 20-year useful
life asset with a 20year useful yes and
I believe there there is some um
probably some Industries are not
included in that um I just need to
double check
that I I think we do need a better
understanding of exactly the impact um I
I think I may have been mistaken that
there was a limit um tied but you know
the section um 172 yeah but but you're
that's a different depreciation yeah
that's the 179 uh expense deduction um
and that that's another bill and
currently there is a limitation in terms
of the maximum amount that can be
deducted that well that bill is mainly
just talking about the LI the maximum
limitation um this bill we probably do
need a better understand exactly you
know for our work session on this
exactly
what is affected so that we can
understand the extent of the uh the
impact yes representative PL yeah I'm
confused when you referred 20270 % you
mean they wouldn't be able to take
depreciation at all no what what the 0%
mean that is the 168k bonus depreciation
the both the business organization will
therefore continue to depreciate on the
regular depreciation okay so if Federal
by in the federal level by 20127 they'll
only be able to depreciate on
a prata basis for over the life of the
asset that's correct okay but no no
accelerated depreciation correct no no
Accel uh well yeah the the modifi the
modified
um makers I I can't remember MCR
modified uh it's whatever it is yes
that's that's one okay they were able to
follow that yes so depreciation will
still be allowed but then there's no
bonus there's
no um early on one lump some
depreciation and then the remainder of
that over the the useful life of the
asset yeah something like modified asset
class reduction or something like that
but it is it is an accelerated
depreciation but this would remove any
bonus above that right that's
correct okay thank
you would anyone else like to testify on
hp1
1531 see n I'll close the public hearing
on
HP yeah I just like to follow up on that
Mr chair and uh ask the Dr provid us
with a copy of uh IRC 168k and their
analysis of what it actually
does okay is that something Dr can
do um a
um a a description of 168 or
168k and also your analysis of what it
does
I think again the whole point here is
we're we're concerned about how does it
affect State finances so we just need a
good understanding of
this okay I'm going to close the public
hearing on
15:31 we'll now open the public hearing
on hb1
1533 I Rec recognize representative
erery thank you Mr chair for the record
my name is Jordan oler Hillsboro 13 town
of Hudson new Hampshire and introducing
1533 relative to the safe harbor
compensation amount under the business
profits tax this bill increases the
amount of the Safe Harbor provision for
compensation under the business profits
tax and provides for biannual increase
in future years based upon the
percentage change in the Consumer Price
Index um essentially what this bill does
is obviates the need for us to
continually make changes
and for a period of time what we we did
was forgot to make that change so we had
to make a a massive change a few years
ago and this just allows for the CPI to
address the uh inflation index um it's a
a fair trade for the smaller businessmen
because what it allows to do is to take
that into consideration so I would urge
Passage
thank you uh do we have any questions
for representative
Hillary seeing none thank
you and now I will invite uh
Aly oh representative elme C city of
Lebanon uh
District 17 this year I can't remember
so anyway uh I just wanted to agree with
my colleagues uh about this on when we
put in reasonable compensation this is
about small
businesses uh
that and um Partnerships actually that
where the member is working in his
business and like a snowplow or somebody
like that on they uh we put in a major
change to the reasonable compensation
law in
2010 um which got delayed because the
Republicans worked against it uh and but
when you took over you um made took the
50,000 that was all Governor Lynch had
allowed us and you made it 75,000 which
is what we had actually
wanted so um this has is a essentially a
bipartisan F figure I checked the
inflation and 100,000 is perfectly
reasonable at this
point uh since
2011 uh
and on I am all
for having originated that idea I am all
for putting in a CPI fix so that we
never end up with small businesses
having to pay um pay more than they
should be paying thank you great thank
you
um I can invite Dr up if anyone has any
questions or them
um you do
oh
oh I don't see any questions for Dr okay
thank you I will now close uh is there
anyone else who wants to testify on hp1
1533 saying none I'll close the public
you at least that one I knew what I was
talking
about okay I will now open the public
hearing on hb1 1536 and recognize
representative erery for the record my
name is Jordan erery I'm still from
Hillsboro 13 which is still the town of
Hudson unless the snow moves Hudson
around somewhere any any rate just U
introducing Bill 1536 FN relative to
increasing the amount of the expense
deduction allowed against the business
profits tax which is similar to uh 15 uh
33 in that it's allowing an expense
deduction this bill increases the amount
under Section
179 IRC 1 Section uh 179 expense
deduction permitted against the business
profits tax so it's again it's a
relationship between uh New Hampshire
tax code and federal tax code and just
makes it easier for the businesses to
make some deductions and this is the
section you were talking about earlier
Mr chair and
with that I'll let IR um Dr explain the
the function and how it operates and all
that stuff because the other ones are
going to have to administer it anyway so
they know thank
you besides it's just sitting in the
back doing nothing you might as well
have them come up here and talk all
right if no one has any questions of
Representative oler we will say thank
up
morning Kim Nong tax policy council with
the
Dr Lauren o solivan senior financial
analyst Dr I see that hasn't changed
since earlier today it's
good all right uh representative Aly you
have a question thank you yes on this uh
amount was last increased in January 1
[Music]
2018 um from 2017 chapter law uh it was
raised at that point from a 100,000 to
500,000 um and I cannot remember the
rationale but we're at 500,000 now this
is considerably more than
inflation uh this is an
an increase yet again in um business um
Prof profits that we are not
taxing uh over the last time we did it
when it was quite a high
increase so why did we end up with a
million
um uh thanks for the question
represented Army um the the um I I guess
the the driver for this uh the bill the
details of the bill came from um rep
representative Janan uh when he
approached us uh to to look into this uh
this section of the code and to see if
um if it can be updated and I believe
that $1 million was uh the amount that
was provided by representative er uh
yeah okay so um can you verify that that
change that represent Aly just mentioned
was um 100 to 500 in 2018 yeah I believe
that's correct um I I don't have those
facts with me right now but I remember
that when we first started it we looked
into the history of of the um of this
section and the the change of uh what it
was before and um how many years ago was
that um I I don't my apologies I don't
have those details with me but I believe
yeah
okay yes represent Al me um I think I
calculated the inflation but I can't
since 18 but I can't remember at this
Point uh what it
was but it was considerably less than
this well I guess the other the other
component to this would be um
certainly looking at inflation but also
just reasonable number was was 100,000 a
reasonable number is 500 well 500,000
was um if it was only
2018 certainly that's higher than
inflation the question
is I guess and I'm not sure what the
answer to this is what is a reasonable
number
um that may be something we want to try
to figure out because I agree if we're
just looking at inflation it's probably
doesn't make sense to go to a million
but if there's other factors that make
um and I'm not sure what I don't know if
you you would know like what is there
how would we determine what a reasonable
number is
I I believe that's a policy question on
what's reasonable or not um okay yeah
fair enough yes representative
fellows so I'm I'm confused um so this
talks about the Internal Revenue code
section
179 that describes a certain kind of
deduction and in the Internal Revenue
code is that 500
100,000 in the code or is there somehow
does it say you can have a deduction but
not say how much in the Internal Revenue
code um the the current deduction for
2022 uh for 179 is 1.08
million
1.08 interesting so we are at about the
same I because I was trying to remember
back to when we were talking about this
maybe that was the um that was the
connection because because obviously
that's not not just an inflation
adjusted number I think it was a number
to try to figure out what what makes
um does anyone else have any other
questions on
this yes represent fellow so the same
question I had last time it it says
property well no it says except for
property
so what what kind of expenses are
being deducted here so these expenses
are the the cost of um of the
asset so instead of depreciating the
asset over the life of the of the um the
asset it is then as an expense in the
year of purchase or well in the year
that uh the asset was placed in
service that's the total of all assets
so right it's not like a million dollars
per different that's a total number so
if you've got 50 assets and they total
up to a million or if they total up
higher than that you can only take up to
correct followup representative
fellows so this is ex expense deductions
did did does this go together with the
other Bill be well it's depreciation
expense the other one
about the other one was the percentage
of how much you could take well let uh
Dr explain that what's the difference
between 16 they are similar um both
deals with the the cost of the
asset um whereas um from the federal
perspective uh the 168k bonus
depreciation uh it's a percentage um of
the of the cost of the asset that is
allow uh accelerated on the first year
of placing in service and then the
remainder of that cost of the asset is
is depreciated over the remaining life
of the
asset whereas 179k is
a is a 100% deduction
but up to the total income uh a total
amount of a well a million dollars now
under the bill current law is
500,000 I guess our is is section one
one 168 and Section 179 is there a
crossover that's or they different
assets the the so if the asset if the
taxpayer chooses to use if they if the
asset qualifies for either one and
taxpayer chooses one over the other they
can't do both at the same time so taking
like a double deduction kind of
situation no so that so the taxpayer
okay I think the this
the the a little bit of confusion on my
part anyhow would
be under HP 1531 there's aund um we're
we're talking about 100% deduction with
no limit so why would anyone
ever use this
deduction or am I misunderstanding
um because I guess when they're both
100% then there there won't be any
difference whereas if you're looking
from a federal perspective when you have
that before 100% was like
50% and then it was 100% during tcj and
then there was that phase out each
year-over year it depends I I suppose it
depends on the the business itself if
the business thinks that okay they
rather um allocate that depreciation
spread it out over the number of years
but maybe get a large deduction in the
first year and then still have some
remaining depreciation to offset income
over the the the their future years or
if they want to do the 179 and they
qualify for the 179 take that and take
100% during the first year and then
nothing else for the remainder of the
the useful life of the asset so that
options okay thank you yes represent me
yeah I might have Mi misunderstood
something but how do you not qualify for
179 except by not having enough money to
be able to get to
it yes so the 179
um I I believe the so the 179
is has that limitation of um of that
five
$500,000 um on the federal side on the
federal side that limitation is the
$1.08 million based on a 2.7 million
capital expenditure spend capital
expenditure uh
spend um so it the 179 has very has that
sort of income limitation requirement
that needs to be looked into before they
can take that deduction whereas the 168k
that yes follow up so does that that
mean that um a business that's capable
of um buying a
179 but a startup or another small
business smaller business could only use
the other
yeah and the asset classes are the same
they cover the same asset
classes they are same uh there might be
some some differences but usually uh in
the lar in the large part they are the
same there there probably are some
some distinctions between the 179 assets
and the 168k
assets yes represent
fellows so what if the company is
headquarters in New Hampshire does this
apply to assets that they buy and but
they the asset never comes to New
Hampshire it could be somewhere
else it does not this bill or the
current law for 179 does not distinguish
whether the the business organization is
headquartered in New Hampshire or not in
New Hampshire or whether the assets are
placed in service in New Hampshire or
not in New Hampshire as long as it's say
they business profits tax filers and um
and they have these assets that place in
qualify any other
questions represent Aly
so does that mean that if we have a
business
here uh which is doing absolutely no
improvement of its business
here uh but it has it's making
improvements in a bunch of other places
we're paying for
[Music]
elsewhere
so well I mean what's interesting about
this is we aren't changing the the
spirit of the law we're changing an
um my my belief is there's got to be
some um we need to look into it but
there's got to be some
thing that makes sense about this
otherwise yes follow if I could on it
was only fairly recently four
years five years more on where that we
had an actual uh policy
analysis capability in
Dr and so what we were doing in in
earlier years was not benefiting
from a number of misconceptions that
we'v been operating on
before so I think it's it's worth
examining things as we go
through yes represent ORS thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
so if I can clarify I believe that
whether it is or isn't which you
struggle with which I was thinking about
also the amount is immaterial would you
agree
or the changes in material
subjective well I just mudded that water
didn't I thank you he doesn't have boots
on yes representative fellows so I you
know this is my first year on Ways and
Means and and so you know I just try to
I need things at fairly simple level to
try to understand them so my
understanding of like the business
profits tax is that if a big company
like Walmart you know they have huge
amounts of Revenue huge amounts of
expenditures the amount of profit that
they have are taxed on by New Hampshire
is in relation to the amount of
Assets in that they have in New
Hampshire or the amount of their say
something about we're they're not paying
taxes on on all of their entire
operation just a little slice of it in
New Hampshire is that and and then then
I if that's like somewhere in the
ballpark of
of correct then this given them these
deductions for assets purchased in the
whole country world just doesn't make
any sense to me so can you help me
understand
it so uh a lar business organization
carrying conducting business activity in
New Hampshire and outside of New
Hampshire uh will potentially be filing
a a a unitary um combined filing return
uh where
it's business income would be a
portioned so uh that portion that's
subject that's a portion to New
Hampshire would be subject to um that
will create a factor ratio uh multiply
with the taxable item in New Hampshire
and multiply with the uh the applicable
New Hampshire tax rate um the the
apportionment factor is changed from the
Tre Factor appr pment the Tre factor
aport which was the sales payroll and
property so the numerator of that factor
is the sales the New Hampshire sales
over the total sales everywhere sales
the payroll factor is the New Hampshire
payroll over the total payroll and the
property factor is the New Hampshire
property over the total property uh that
has changed to the single sales factor
which is not only just sales so it's
just New Hampshire sales over total
sales everywhere the property the number
of assets that's um value of the assets
in New Hampshire does not affect the um
factor I think that I think that kind of
I mean I'll let you do a follow-up but I
think that kind of answers the question
that we just had a few minutes back
where the question was asked is somebody
else benefiting from that the answer is
it's a portioned so if they're if
they're just trying to do that and
barely doing any business in New
Hampshire they're not going to be able
to deduct that full amount they can only
deduct a percentage that's related to
what business they're doing in New
Hampshire and that that's kind of the
the the gate that that throttles it back
yes follow up so I understand the factor
that's like a essentially it's going to
be a percentage of their profits that
they you know I don't know 2% or
something that they owe to New Hampshire
but these bills are
reducing what their profit would be
because they they are able to take those
deductions for those purchases in the
first year right and then just to Echo
what representative Jen saying these
adjustments are before approp uh before
apportionment and they will still be
subject to the apportionment
the well then they have to be a
portioned correct so if if there's a
million dollars to deduct but they're
only doing 2% of their business you can
correct me if I'm wrong 2% of their
business in New Hampshire then they can
only deduct 2% of the $1 million yes so
you take the deduction you you get the
deductions first and then you come up
with a net number and then apply that
net number against the oppor factor how
what's the New Hampshire piece of it
like um if you say it was 2% it was 2%
in New Hampshire and then multiply that
with the uh the New Hampshire rate the
tax rate yes representative ORS thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question would you believe that
accounting is not cut and dry that it's
not just plus and minuses and that it's
very
complicated and that the answer the
depends yes I do believe um accounting
is complicated that was very
any other
questions all right and I'm sure we will
talk about this some more during a work
session um yes if if I thank you Mr
chair if I could just jump in for a
second and and say would you believe
that accounting and tax law the tax law
is like six million pages I believe in
the federal sector New Hampshire's I'm
sure less than that
and and would you believe that it's very
convoluted would you believe
that yes I I would believe that yeah
thank you very much okay any other
representative
you thank you Mr chair for the
opportunity to add to this and and
excuse me one minute uh I'll need Dr to
fill out unfortunately three more pink
cards HP 1531 1533 and
1536 thank you yes representative
oler uh the the listening to the
discussion came to mind a new business
that's coming into uh well two of them
actually into Hudson 500,000 square foot
uh Warehouse operations both of these
facilities will have electric uh ponies
or Don
uh trucks to move trailers around on the
property that's a vehicle that would
that would is going to cost it's a
depreciable expense to that particular
company uh for the operation of that
particular facility um and would be
subject to 168k because it's a
short-term
depreciable item uh depending upon who
makes batteries it may be very short
term the first time it gets wet or it
may be long term depending upon what
goes on um but at any rate that that
would be an example of that while inside
the
business they're going to be using some
Advanced robotics from uh and they're
working with u the company down there on
route 3i robot uh
for taking items that come off of the
trucks that are put out and then stacked
up and stored according to this then
pulled out of stock and shipped out to
the various distribution points this is
a selection for distribution warehouse
It's called a distribution warehouse
surprisingly um that
robot its own cost besides
inflation
is rather
expensive but we all benefit from it
because we pay less for the broom that
we buy or the iroot that we buy although
you can buy one I'm not going to um at
any rate that's that's I I I would hope
that Dr could determine whether or not
that's a a good example of the
differences between the application of
179 and 168 whereas one is a shortterm
in my understanding and the other one is
a major expense to the company whether
they're allowing uh on the federal level
1.8 million we're going to be allowing 1
million at the at the state level for a
a massive infusion of a different
product and different U um
operation device represent PL is it true
that for purposes of taxes we don't care
whether that's in new H Hudson New
Hampshire or California it's the amount
of sales in New Hampshire over sales
Nationwide times the profit Prof that's
calculated with this calculation
whatever they said yeah but it's it's a
material that is in New Hampshire this
case it's sales in New Hampshire well
yeah but the operation in of the
companies that I provided were are going
to be both um on exe well on the old
golf course and on Friar's Drive in
you is there anyone else who wishes to
1536 seeing none I will close the public
well yeah now you can take an hour for
lunch you don't have to come back here
um so tomorrow um I will see hopefully
see you all and and a few more uh 10:00
and
um we have we have five five again five
bills to do I don't know that you know
again we'll have to take the the
temperature of how things are going and
maybe take a lunch break or maybe get it
done if we get done by one I think
that's
preferable tomorrow yes it's 10
o' no that that was a suggestion I think
um
Sugg for for future uh scheduling
um and did you all see my email about
future scheduling thank
you so we're going to schedule something
I'm going to try to schedule something
nothing will be next week There's no
any turn your
microphone
so um representative Sanborn had a list
of all of our and he was emailing to our
home
asked um she was things were being
emailed to my home address email address
and which is way more convenient for me
than having it go into the big pile on
the the ledge is there some way that you
can send us
um emails to those
addresses
um I've been I've been using the way you
know the ways and means uh shorthand uh
address um but um yeah I mean I can
um I don't know that I have all those
addresses but I could add yours may with
Karen
Karen well I've been using the
business okay yeah Jordan I used my own
but I told
ledge it legislative it and the
my
okay okay yeah let me just let me know
Isis well in case you do you not have
access to your legislative you just
much
all
that